let's talk about hydrogen bonds
depicted here i have three different
types of molecules on the left i have
ammonia each ammonia molecule has one
nitrogen bonded to three hydrogens in
the middle i have something you're
probably very familiar with in fact
you're made up of it which is water each
oxygen is bonded to two hydrogens and
then here on the right i have hydrogen
fluoride each fluorine is bonded to one
hydrogen
now why are these types of molecules
interesting and what does that have to
do with hydrogen bonds and the simple
answer is in each of these cases you
have hydrogen bonded to a much more
electronegative atom even though these
are covalent bonds they're going to be
polar covalent bonds you are going to
have a bond dipole moment that goes from
the hydrogen to the more electronegative
atom from the hydrogen to the more
electronegative atom from the hydrogen
to the more electronegative atom the
more electronegative atom is going to
hog the electrons the electrons are
going to spend more time around that so
that end of the molecule is going to
have a partial negative charge and then
the ends with the hydrogen those are
going to have partial
positive charges
another way to think about it is if you
added these dipole moments you would
have a net dipole for the entire
molecule that would look something that
would look something like that so we are
dealing with polar molecules and the
polarity comes from both the asymmetry
and you have a very electronegative atom
bonded to hydrogen oxygen very
electronegative atom bonded to hydrogen
so this end of the molecule is partially
negative this end of the molecule or
these ends of the molecule are partially
positive for hydrogen fluoride this end
is partially positive this end is
partially negative and so what do you
think could happen when these molecules
interact with each other the nitrogen
end right over here of this ammonia
could be attracted to one of these
hydrogens that has a partially positive
charge right over there
or this
hydrogen the partial positive charge
might be attracted to that nitrogen that
has a partial negative charge and this
attraction between the partial positive
hydrogen end and the partially negative
end of another molecule those are
hydrogen bonds and they are an
intermolecular force that will
be additive to the total intermolecular
force from say things like london
dispersion forces which makes you have a
higher boiling point than you would have
if you just thought about london
dispersion forces
and to make that clear you can look at
this chart
you can see all of these molecules are
formed between period two elements and
hydrogen
in fact all of these molecules have
similar
molar masses methane ammonia hydrogen
fluoride and water if we were just
thinking about london dispersion forces
lung dispersion forces are proportional
to the polarizability
of a molecule which is proportional to
the electron cloud size which is
proportional to the molar mass and
generally speaking as you go from
molecules formed with period two
elements to period three elements to
period four elements to period five
elements you do see that as the molar
mass of those molecules increase there
is that general upward trend of the
boiling point and that's due to the
london dispersion forces but at for any
given period you do see the separation
in particular you see a lot of
separation for the molecules formed with
oxygen fluorine and nitrogen these
molecules despite having similar molar
masses have very different boiling
points so there must be some other type
of intermolecular forces at play above
and beyond london dispersion forces and
the simple answer is yes what you have
at play are the hydrogen bonds
now some of you might be wondering well
look at these molecules formed with
period three elements and hydrogen or
period four elements in hydrogen they
also don't have the same boiling point
even though you would expect similar
london dispersion forces because they
have similar molar masses and the
separation that you see here in boiling
points this too would be due to other
things other than london dispersion
forces in particular dipole dipole
forces would be at play but what you can
see is the spread is much higher for
these molecules formed with nitrogen and
hydrogen fluorine and hydrogen and
oxygen and hydrogen and that's because
hydrogen bonds can be viewed as the
strongest form of
dipole-dipole forces
hydrogen bonds are a special case of
dipole-dipole
forces when we're talking about hydrogen
bonds we're usually talking about a
specific bond dipole the bond between
hydrogen and a more electronegative atom
like nitrogen oxygen and fluorine and so
we're specifically talking about that
part of the molecule that hydrogen part
that has a partially positive charge
being attracted to the partially
negative end of another molecule so it's
really about a bond dipole with hydrogen
bonds versus a total molecular dipole
when we talk about dipole-dipole
interactions in general and so you can
imagine it doesn't even just have to be
hydrogen bonds between a like molecule
you could have hydrogen bonds between an
ammonia molecule and a water molecule or
between a water molecule and a hydrogen
fluoride molecule and i mentioned that
these are really important in biology
this right over here is a close-up of
dna you can see that the base pairs in
dna you can imagine the rungs of the
ladder those are formed by hydrogen
bonds between base pairs so those
hydrogen bonds are strong enough to keep
that double helix together but then
they're not so strong that they can't be
pulled apart when it's time to replicate
or transcribe the dna
hydrogen bonds are also a big deal in
proteins you learn in biology class that
proteins are made up of chains of amino
acids and the function is heavily
influenced by the shape of that protein
and that shape is influenced by hydrogen
bonds that might form between the amino
acids that make up the protein so
hydrogen bonds are everywhere there are
many hydrogen bonds in your body right
now mainly not just because of the dna
mainly because you're mostly water so
life as we know it would not exist
without hydrogen bonds